some asmr stuff right here
it's like uh the sound of when you walk
on the crisp autumn leaves you know
[Music]
hey everyone this is inca and i am super
excited to be here today to make one of
the most extravagant recipes from
tasty's new cookbook
tasty over the top
it has a lot of creative and inspiring
new recipes that kind of celebrate what
tasty is known for show stopping
insta-worthy very visual recipes that
are as fun to make as they are to eat
today i'm gonna be making the rainbow
unicorn vodka and the reason i picked
this recipe is because well i love bread
i love playing around with colors this
recipe uses natural food coloring matcha
and pitaya two of my favorite flavors so
let's get started
hair's tied i'm gonna start off by
making the yeast mixture first i'm gonna
do is actually melt some butter and
we're gonna set it down i'm gonna go
ahead and add in the sugar now milk as
well
this is the base of something good you
already know that add in the yeast oh it
smells so good already actually let it
rest for about 10 minutes perfect time
for a snack break if you're asking me so
i'm gonna go do that and we'll be right
back
[Music]
i'm back with some more dry ingredients
i have two bowls of flour here because
we're gonna make two different colored
doughs one with matcha and one with
pitaya i'm gonna put the pitaya in this
one and then i'm gonna put the matcha in
this one and a little bit of salt for
the pitaya i'm gonna add in an egg my
yeast mixture as you can see is now
split into two bowls and one i'm going
to put right in here and we're just
going to combine this now oh okay look
at that pink i think this is actually
pretty well combined at this point and
this is going to rest for 30 minutes in
the meantime i'm gonna work on my matcha
dough
all right so now i have my two bowls of
dough here they're gonna rest for 30
minutes get a little beauty sleep and
we'll be right back
okay so while the dough is resting i'm
actually gonna get started on the icing
i'm gonna go ahead and put some
butterfly pea flour into my warm milk
here i'm going to give it a little bit
of a stir already it's actually already
changing the color a little bit i'm
going to let this sit here for around an
hour
all right friends i have my beautifully
risen dough babies here as you can see
they are now super puffy wow it is soft
this brings me so much satisfaction
little
flower action oh my gosh gonna roll it
out i'm trying to aim for a 6 by 12 inch
rectangle the measurements actually do
matter a little bit and i think this is
looking
pretty good honestly
just make sure
all right friends first rectangle
done
are we good to move on and same thing
just gonna roll this out
and now what we're gonna do is actually
marry the two essentially pinch them
together like so so they form one dough
now that i have that together i am going
to actually brush on some melted butter
so no holding back vodka is a treat
and then the next thing i'm going to do
is add on some fruity cereal it's a very
nostalgic flavor for me and i honestly
just also love
the crunch here i think that looks
pretty good that looks pretty good am i
being too generous am i being too
generous okay i think i i'm a little too
greedy here already all right great i'm
gonna go in with my hands here and just
this is some some asmr stuff right here
it's like uh the sound of when you walk
in the woods on the crisp autumn leaves
you know
this is art this is straight up just art
look at that this could belong in the
moma is looking pretty good to me so i
am going to
roll it up this is a
slightly trickier part but we're gonna
go for it oh my gosh
yeah
look at that we have a beautiful dual
colored cylinder thing going on what i
want to do is actually
cut it in half
okay we're just gonna go for it and just
try
to
cut it in half here this is where we
play like really intense music because
like
is oh
one last cut here all the way down in
the middle
the reveal oh
look at that okay it's a little a little
crazy right now but you can see
the cross section here this is the part
where because we're making a vodka we're
gonna try and twist it together by doing
a crisscross here same thing on this end
looks pretty good if i do say so myself
okay great just put this this big guy in
there carefully uh
help okay um carefully scoop this up and
just place it right in there
oh my
gosh
oh
the panic i had for a second okay
amazing so now that i have this i am
pretty much ready to go bake this now so
while the bobcat is baking in the oven i
am going to finish the icing that i
started a little while ago as you can
see
this milk is now a very very nice shade
of blue i'm gonna make two different
colored icings one is blue and one will
be purple all right we're just gonna
start off by making a big batch of blue
put that in the powdered sugar that we
have here and gently mix that up all
right this is looking pretty good i'm
going to separate some out
and
make my purple icing just like a little
magic trick because if you add lemon to
butterfly pea flower tea
it will become purple
you see
how it becomes violet and there you go
ready for decoration i think now it's
about time to check on the vodka
okay
look at how good that looks this smells
amazing smells like buttery brioche
bread the fruity cereal just like i love
how it clung onto the dough and now to
add some decoration i'm gonna start with
the
blue icing here
oh my gosh all right now let's do the
purple icing oh my gosh there's a lot
but you know that's what we're aiming
for today
and now i'm gonna add sprinkles because
you can never have enough sprinkles
maybe a little bit more why not
there's some little stars here that i'm
just gonna add to complete the look
little pearls on there too why not we're
going for extravagant so extravagant it
is this is it this is the rainbow
unicorn vodka there's a lot of colors
going on it is very sparkly
i'm very excited to cut into this and
taste it i wonder if it's gonna taste as
fun as it looks all right it is time to
cut this bread oh my gosh
wow
it smells amazing smells buttery brioche
um i'm gonna take a big bite here
oh yeah that's some good bread honestly
what i really love about this is the
texture of the foodie cereal and like
the little pops of fruity flavor i
actually do taste the matcha and the
icing kind of just brings it all
together this is really good
but really making this vodka was such a
fun experience i love that we got to
play around with so many different
colors so many different flavors it all
came together to create this like
beautiful sort of like centerpiece and
honestly there's so many more fun
recipes like that in this book tasty
over the top that i'm also very excited
to try
i really think that this is like a great
cookbook to have if you want to impress
your friends your family really i also
think this cookbook would be like
a perfect gift this is something i would
want to give to my friends and family
because i want them to have fun when
they're cooking and like just enjoy
these new experiences so yeah go get the
cookbook if you haven't yet tasty over
the top you're gonna have so much fun
with this it's the perfect gift and i
will see you all later
[Music]